Il y a deux ans quand j'ai commencé à monter sur scène ici au Panamar café à Paris
voici un extrait de ma toute première scène filmée par Cyprien
"Ma grand-mère me disait, juste avant qu'on la débranche, *rire* elle me disait écoute Norman !"
Je me suis rendu compte que c'était moins facile de parler devant des vrais gens que devant une caméra
"-Ca va mec ?
-Ouais ça va"
mais j'avais envie de ce challenge alors je me suis entraîné sept jours sur sept pendant deux ans
"Norman c'est des vidéos sur Youtube. Peut-être que certains connaissent, j'sais pas ?
*silence puis rire* Voilà gros succès ! *rire* "
Puis deux ans plus tard j'ai la chance de pouvoir jouer dans des Zénith complets
*cris du public*
"On dirait pas comme ça, moi je suis un mec hyper connu, un hyper célèbre, chez les gens qui sont en CE1"
*rire du public*
Cette tournée des zénith c'est l'une des plus belles expériences de ma vie alors j'ai voulu en partager un petit bout avec vous
histoire de vous montrer un peu ce que je fais depuis deux ans quand je suis pas sur youtube
"4600 personnes ! OOK !"
*cris du public*
J'ai joué partout. Y a plein de dates qui se sont super bien passées et d'autres moins
"Attrape le ! Attrape le !"
Lui c'est le mec qui assure la première partie de mon spectacle c'est mon pote Noman
Oui, j'avais une chance sur un milliard de tomber sur un mec ayant un prénom qui ressemble à 99% au mien
finalement c'est plutôt un hasard-rigolo
"-Ah, tu veux un autographe de moi ?
-Ah non ça va aller, merci."
"-Tu en veux un de Noman aussi ?
-Non"
"Voilàààà ! C'est Noman ! Pas Norman. Tu oublies le r, ok ? il n'y a pas de r."
"J'ai une petite surprise pour vous c'est ma première partie"
"Il faut savoir que google ne me reconnait pas. Si tu tapes Noman sur google en général il va te dire
vouliez-vous dire norman fait des vidéos ? *rire* Il ne me connait pas"
"-C'est la première date de la tournée...
-Là au moment où tu me parles, tu es en train de te torcher"
*rire de Norman*
"J'adore Fanta ! J'adore vraiment Fanta ! "
Lui c'est Gérard mon batteur oui j'ai un batteur
Son truc à lui c'est qu'il fait des débats surtout enfin vraiment surtout et de manière permanente "Quand tu vois le prix du cacao
en Arabie Saoudite
Moi je suis désolé quoi ça me donne plus envie de manger du chocolat.
T'imagines si tu ramènes ça à la vision humaine
On s'en fou
Tu es vraiment pas intéressant"
Lui c'est Titouch, il est fait de muscles de muscles et de muscles.
-Tu fais de la muscu là ? - Ouais j'vais y aller -T'en a bien besoin
Titouch il s'occupe de plein de trucs notamment avertir les gens ne pas filmer durant le spectacle
d'ailleurs pour attirer leur attention discrètement il utilise un petit laser en gros il l'azerrifi les gens quoi
bien sûr mon spectacle serait rien sans les 30 courageux de techniciens qui installent et désinstallent ma scène chaque jour
non j'ai pas la grosse tête moi j'suis  un mec simple tu vois tous les jours je veux dire bonjour à mes potos technicien ça va Manu ?
-non mais Jibé  -Jibé  pff n'importe quoi
-Greg ça va mon pote ? -Yoann -Yoann?
-ça va Vlad ?  -Ah non moi je travaille pas ici
tu travailles pas ici
avec qui on travaille ensemble pour que chaque soir le spectacle soit parfait
Non franchement j'ai bossé avec des gens super pro  parfois même un peu trop pro
-Bonjour monsieur vous avez un badge ?
-J'ai pas le badge il est dans ma loge mais...  -Si vous vous avez pas le badge vous rentrer pas
- C'est moi qui fais le spectacle euh... l'artiste de la euh...   -Si vous avez pas de badge vous rentrer pas
-Ici sur le bouton select je... ALGÉRIE!!
Ah Kader il est arrivé ? celui sans qui mon spectacle n'aurait jamais existé
c'est bien sûr mon metteur en scène Kader  c'est un peu mon mentor il connaît plein de trucs qui parle le plein de trucs
il parle aussi beaucoup l'algérie hein en fait
il parle tout le temps de l'algérie
quelqu'un a vu mon drapeau algérien
La c'est le moment du spectacle où tu dois être plus sincères qui doit être...  -Tu sais que edith piaf  -Est algérienne  -Comment tu sais ?
C'est heu... L'instinct
Parfois après le spectacle
on sort un peu en boîte pour  se détendre mais c'est vrai qu'un mardi soir en boîte dans les vosges à saint dié
l'ambiance est pas toujours au top
*Solitude*
Dans mon spectacle je parle de plein de trucs un peu comme dans mes vidéos
je parle de sujets qui nous concernent tous je parle un petit peu de ma vie aussi notamment de mon métier un petit peu bizarre
ce qu'on appelle un youtuber tu vois
alors dit que je dis ce mot je-je trouve des petites guillemets comme ça c'est un métier un peu spécial
il ya plein de métiers au tout pas employer les guillemets tu vas faire je présente c'est moi votre chirurgien
Ouais je m'occupais personnellement de votre cref du coeur
Donc voilà tout se passe bien la fin vous devriez être vivant euh...
tu peux pas faire ça quoi qu'il en soit cette tournée je la kiffe vous avez déjà été 150 mille spectateurs à venir me voir
si j'essaie vraiment important le nombre de spectateurs est ce que l'important c'est pas le plaisir de l'art girard on s'en fout
va t'en merci
mon spectacle en tout cas il est fait pour tous du coup il y avait vraiment de tout des filles mignonnes des couples mignon
des tatoués des bavardes
des bien coiffé décoiffé chelou des sans cheveux des darons
des licornes
des mamies des re-couples mignons des re-mamies etc je suis bien content parce que même mon père est venu voir mon spectacle
enfin je veux dire il était présent à mon spectacle quoi
Finalement la seule personne qui a raté mon passage sur scène où je parle de mon père ah bah c'est mon père
tu as vu le passage où je parle de toi?
-Quel passage ?  -Au milieu du spectacle là
-Un moment donné je parle de toi  -Je me rappelle pas
voilà vous en savez un peu plus sur moi et mon métier en dehors de youtube qui a remercier l'équipe vidéo qui nous a suivis
pendant ces longs mois de tournée à travers la france la suisse la belgique
ainsi que la marque fanta qui nous a donné les moyens de réaliser cette vidéo en coulisse
râler parce que sans eux dans cette vidéo elle ressemblait à ça avant
Sachez que je n'oublis pas d'où je viens je sais grâce à qui j'en suis là et je n'oublie pas chaque soir de vous remercier sur
scène j'aimerai faire un feu d'artifice et un tonerre d'applaudissement pour les million d'inconnues d'abonnés, d'internautes
qui me font confiance depuis quatre ans on dit dans une vidéo
c'est grâce à eux que je suis là ce soir
vous pleurez s'il vous plaît
Voilà ma tournée est terminée mais je continue mon spectacle ici à paris au Palace 8 rue du faubourg Montmartre
dans le 9e à partir du 15 octobre 2015 alors venez ça va vraiment être très cool j'ai hâte de vous voir
à très très vite ciao à l'époque il n'y avait pas à l'époque
on ne googlisait pas
on lycossait sur lycos
on se donnait rencart le soir sur msn pour s'envoyer et wiz